oh man Luis I am fired up we have a hell
of a show today and I know that there is
going to be a portion of our audience
that is not going to like me after
today's show but you know what I know
that there is a portion of our audience
that is going to appreciate that I am
NOT doing things or not doing things for
optics on the program and I am telling
it to you like I see it and like I think
it's important for progressives to know
what am I talking about well last week I
talked to you about a whole bunch of
people emailing me saying David are you
voting for Jill Stein the Green Party
candidate because if you supported
Bernie the obvious correct thing is
obviously to support Jill Stein and I
explained no I'm not Jill Stein is
fundamentally anti science on a number
of issues including GMO she is
irrationally anti Israeli in a way that
I could never ever get behind because no
sensible rational person could ever come
to the conclusion she has come to on
that issue and it's gotten way WAY worse
really really bad a video was sent to me
of Jill Stein saying that Wi-Fi could be
dangerous for our brains and I'm gonna
play the clip for you it's actually not
clear from the clip that she knows the
difference between Wi-Fi and wireless
phones it is just an utter mess okay
first Jill Stein says and I'll play it
for you that education should move away
from screens that that that we should
should not have kids on screens in
school which we could talk about screen
usage but if you want students to be
ready for college and the real world you
need a reasonable amount of computer
work to be going on we'll listen to that
and then we'll get to the Wi-Fi part and
it is just this is just flat-out anti
science stuff the stuff of of conspiracy
websites okay take a look wonderful
health issues social issues you know you
name it but to be staring at
you know I mean we already know that
kids who get put in front of TVs you
know instead of interacting this is not
good in all kinds of ways and is just
it's it's not good for their cognitive
development it's not good for their
social development I mean that is
incredible that kids in kindergarten we
should be moving away from screens at
all levels of Education not moving into
them yeah and this is another corporate
ruse you know this is another gimmick to
try to make make a buck make big bucks
in fact and education and teachers and
communities suffer so we need to stand
up to that thank you yes right I mean we
should not be subjecting um kids brains
especially to that and you know we don't
follow that issue in this country but in
in Europe where they do you know they're
they have good precautions around
wireless maybe not good enough you know
because it's very hard to study this
stuff you know we make guinea pigs out
of whole populations and then we
discover how many died you know and this
is like the paradigm for how Public
Health worked in this country and it's
outrageous you know I mean this is why
we need to take back really not just our
schools you know and and our electoral
system you know we really need to take
back the whole institution of how we
this is whoo okay this is not a thinking
progressive and it's not even clear she
knows what she's talking about
the question seems to be about Wi-Fi and
there are completely unsubstantiated
claims that Wi-Fi could cause cancer
that the radiation is bad for brains etc
we know about wireless phones and I
don't know if the critique here because
I don't understand exactly is the
critique that she's saying there is
there is something to Wi-Fi and brains
or is she just not understanding the
difference between Wi-Fi and mobile
phones I don't know but it is a non
science mess Wi-Fi has been studied
there is no reasonable evidence at all
that it poses any risk to health and the
articles keep getting posted and you
might read headlines on YouTube about
Wi-Fi and health but there is no good
science saying Wi-Fi is bad for people
it has been studied and it comes down
Louis to understanding types of
radiation not getting not worth getting
into now but this is non science
mumbo-jumbo there was nothing to this
yeah it's the getting away from screens
thing that kind of irritates me as well
it's um yeah but it's easy to fall into
that trap she's she's in that camp it's
easy to do a cursory internet reason you
know search of Jill Stein and say oh
yeah she seems pretty level-headed and
right and I like what she stands for but
there are some serious concerns here
there's also been serious debate about
Jill Stein's position on vaccines and
the debate has been because she's
previously taken a pretty nebulous
stance about it The Washington Post
finally got Jill Stein to be more direct
about her stance on vaccines and it is
disturbing
she started off fine talking about the
importance of vaccines I'll put up the
first quote for you here where she says
I think there's no question vaccines
have been critical in ridding us of the
scourge of many diseases etc etc etc the
problem though is that people do not
trust the Food and Drug Administration
or even CDC for that matter where
corporate and pharmaceutical influence
where corporate influence in the
pharmaceutical industry have a lot of
influence okay fair enough
and then here's where it goes completely
non science woo mumbo jumbo where she
continues and says as a medical doctor
and now this is really low because her
experience as a medical doctor has no
bearing on any of what she's talking
about with regard to vaccines but she
says as a medical doctor there was a
time where I looked very closely at
those issues and not all those issues
were completely resolved there were
concerns among physicians about what the
vaccination schedule meant the toxic
substances like mercury which used to be
rampant in vaccines there were real
questions that needed to be addressed I
think some of them at least have been
addressed I don't know if all of them
have been addressed and you might say
well no big deal she's sort of dancing
around the whole mercury toxicity
vaccine schedule thing she's using her
title of doctor to appear to be
particularly qualified to comment about
vaccines when she's not the mercury
thing has been totally debunked and if
you're going to email me and I know some
of you will and say well David Snopes
said Jill Stein is right on vaccines
number one no one source is ever always
right so yes Snopes
an article defending Jill Stein but four
or five other reputable skeptic pro
science blogs have said well listen both
Jill Stein and Snopes are wrong on this
so Louis this is not someone that I
would ever support and I have
disagreements with Hillary Clinton on
specific elements of foreign policy or I
would rather the minimum wage be 15
rather than $12 or whatever but this is
just fundamentally anti science nonsense
and I'll mention also the Green Party
supports funding homeopathy which has
been debunked as not a valid treatment
or cure for any condition or symptom
period homeopathy is nothing and the
Green Party not necessarily Junt Jill
Stein but the Green Party supports
funding that I don't want anything to do
with this no the party should really be
focusing more on their what they should
really they should sound like Bernie
Sanders yeah they really need to get
away from this stuff and you know it's
just as easy to do a cursory search of
Hillary Clinton and think that
everything is wonderful and then you add
to this the reality that Jill Stein
cannot and will not be the president
just add that into your equation I know
it's great to have in other parties but
just consider that